Russia has launched a large scale
missile attack across Ukraine at the
start of the morning Rush Hour residents
in the capital ke took shelter in Metro
stations as the entire country was put
under alert several strikes hit
residential and Industrial sites in the
eastern city of K keev let's go to assed
beg who's live for us in keev ased what
more can you tell us about this
attack yes according to authorities here
there saying that Russia launched a
large scale missile strike and as you
said some residents in Kei were seen
heading to shelters now we understand
that the cities of CR khv Deno and
zaparo were all targeted now the
authorities in karv Ukraine's second
largest city say uh there were about
four strikes uh and that the residential
uh buildings were hit either by Falling
Dey when those anti-aircraft uh defense
systems uh intercept those missiles or
by direct hits now the governor of K
says one person was injured in C that
Central City in Ukraine we understand a
shopping mall has been hit and two
people injured there now according to
the Ukrainian Air Force Russia used uh
aircraft bombers uh this time round now
yes the ukrainians are saying this is a
large scale attack and there have been
several cities targeted but it doesn't
seem as large scale as the attack on the
29th of December which Ukraine said was
the most massive attack since the start
of the war now these air strikes do seem
like a daily occurrence now K the second
largest city almost gets hit every
single day uh but so far this is the
information that we have this war has
been going on for nearly two years now
and there seems to be no letup uh in
these air strikes that's a beg there for
us in ke thank
you